moutiama les mollets ce faiseur et
sauver comme 32 autres chiens il va être
recueilli par une association de
protection animale
elles étaient plusieurs venu ce matin
pour évacuer les uns après les autres
les pensionnaires rescapés de l'élevage
de mme halimi
cette décision vous avez par oui madame
c'est pas c'est pas non c'est sont des
cas d'arrêt et voilà c'est bien triste
les cadavres de dix sept chiens et deux
chats ont été retrouvés en début de
semaine dans cet élevage en activité
depuis 20 ans et qui n'avait jamais fait
parler de lui jusqu'à dimanche soir
c'est enfin quelqu'un qui était tout cas
probablement sensible aux animaux et qui
a donné l'alerté à une voisine dimanche
dernier cette voisine s'est déplacé
immédiatement elle a constaté la
présence dans un box dans le chien mord
un boxer et elle a contacté la
gendarmerie qui se déplacer sur le champ
les gendarmes se rentrait ainsi que
cette personne cette voisine et ont
constaté ce désastre placé en garde à
vue l'éleveur était appelé à comparaître
dès cet après-midi devant le tribunal
pour mauvais traitements détention de
cadavre et privation de nourriture
c'est un homme abattu dépassé par des
problèmes personnels que les juges ont
trouvé devant eux ils ont décidé de
reporter l'audience à mon sens la sphère
n'était absolument pas en état d'être
jugé la mesure où monsieur a été
extrêmement fatigué et je pense que la
mesure de l'expert psychiatrique quand
nous avions sollicité et qui nous a été
accordée par le tribunal est une très
bonne chose pour pouvoir comprendre et
le juger de la façon la plus la plus
claire et la plus fiable possible
l'audience aura lieu le 23 avril
prochain plusieurs associations de
protection animale se sont portés
parties civiles